i've been in this industry for 42 years
and it was very clear to me from the
first day that my calling
is to help people achieve
their life goals and live a life of
dignity and security
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitech and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel at stanford
leap and birthright excel and in media
partnership with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders and today
we're going to be talking about
financial planning for everyone meet dan
dobre chairman of the board globalnet
israel
dan was the founder of the union of
financial planners in israel ufpi served
as the first chairman and president of
ufpi
he was the global council representative
for israel for the global community fpsb
from 2012 to 2018 and from january 2019
is a member of the committee for
standards and qualifications for the
european union
sqc
dan dobre welcome to 20 minute leaders
all the way from london how are you
wonderful thank you very much
thank you so much for being here i'm
excited to talk to you about financial
planning and
you know not just in in what that means
but also the way that it shaped your
career and
decades long career uh really
understanding both
working you know and financial planning
but also you know being the ceo of the
of global investment services uh
solutions for israeli institutions
and then the president of the union of
financial planners in israel
and now the chairman of the board of
global net israel investment house and
so a lot of experience in financial
planning and different organizations
that are centered around that and i'd
love to both you know understand your
career a little bit better and the
insights that you've gained from your
career and the inspirations that you've
drawn on throughout your career but also
begin a little bit you know simpler and
higher level about what is financial
planning and why is it such an important
field that drew you so deep into it so
so what what is financial planning and
how did you get so involved with it
well um i've been in this industry for
42 years and it was very clear to me
from the first day that my calling
is to help people achieve
their life goals and live a life of
dignity and security
so you know i've been involved in the
industry almost every single you know
facet of it so
uh you know i worked in an insurance
company for a time i worked in
investment houses i work for the
regulator i work with the banks so i've
actually touched the industry from
almost under clients from almost every
every aspect there of of of the of the
industry
so
it was
and if you you know that when i entered
the industry 42 years ago the industry
was completely focused around selling
products so if you're a bank they were
selling bank products investment house
management of your portfolios insurance
company insurance products pensions and
stuff like that so everyone was focused
around products and by the way still is
okay it still is because the regulators
don't regulate people don't regulate
families they regulate
products
so the way they think is about it's
always about products it's so it's very
difficult to take them off that uh train
tracks
now
uh approximately 20 something years ago
i was in the states and then i hit
financial planning
financial planning is something
completely is is a different way of
thinking
so it's a movement from product to
family instead of having
sitting down and trying to find out what
products suit
different families or people
basically financial planning looks at
the family and tries to help them
achieve their life goals using a
methodology an academic methodology for
working with the family which includes
you know uh first of all understanding
the the the economic side the financial
side of the family
income expenses assets liabilities cash
flows
and life goals uh then building asset
allocations trying to build
you know how the investments need to
look in order to
achieve those life goals
uh then
a sensitivity start a little bit of risk
management
uh tax management
uh
creating passive income and then
transfer of assets from generation to
generation but the most important thing
about financial planning is working with
the family
it's actually looking at you trying to
become part of your challenges your life
journey in order to help you achieve
what you want to achieve in your life
and we don't sell products
we look for solutions and that's the
difference
i was talking to one of my friends
who was say
the vice regulator of europe and a
scottish guy called ian and he said to
me
listen dan the industry will never
change until we stop talking about
products and we start talking about
solutions we don't want to sell people
stuff we want to help people
uh achieve their life goals using
different kinds of solutions that we
create for them
right so that's that's what financial
planning is all about
it's a journey
just the way i understand you know are
we talking only about high net worth
families that that have lots of capital
to be deployed and they're just not sure
where to deploy or or is this a little
bit of a broader idea that that can be
assimilated to to different to two
different families with different
socio-economic positions
yeah
so
financial planning has nothing to do
about social economic
okay because basically everyone has life
goals everyone wants to achieve
something everyone wants to live a life
everyone has challenges
the thing is that as you become more
complicated
your challenges become more challenging
okay so if you
so uh
naturally a lot of high net worth or or
the high net in in net worth individuals
you know basically have been
working with financial planners for a
long time it's slowly coming down the
ladder
it's not nothing to do basically the
only
issue around financial planning is can
you afford it
so i think that no financial planner
sits down says i don't want to work with
him i do want to work with him you just
you know like every other professional
you have to pay them you have to
remember financial planners as a
fiduciary standard so he doesn't get
commissions
and it's also you know an issue of
culture
so the client also has to accept the
fact that he needs to pay the client
directly the uh planner directly the
professional sure he pays them anyway
because you have to take into account
when you're buying a product the the
cost of that product is factored into
the the product
so if you're now
getting advice you don't need to pay the
commissions so it should be cheaper
so in the end it's a uh
it's a it's a culture thing and it's you
know you
i think that
today
more and more people are aware
that they need this kind of help because
the world has become more complicated so
anyway it's moved down the ladder today
i would say let's say not mass market
the mass affluent market okay
so if we're looking at people who are
retiring they need help
okay there's tax issues there's so many
issues that they they need a
professional to help them
so
if
ten years ago they would never think of
taking of using any uh assistance today
they need that kind of assistance
but uh basically uh
as you move along in life when you get
to a uh a junction where you need to
make a decision where you need to choose
something where you need to work you
know you need to solve a problem with
your on your taxes you've you've got an
inheritance you want it then you then
you start thinking about getting
assistance
you can go to a commission based
professional and then you know that
you're not getting objective advice
because
a financial planner puts clients
interests before his own
he has to
okay so
when i work with my clients
i become my client for a moment i want
it's an empathic uh
um
a profession i need to become him i need
to understand his values i need to
understand his aspirations his dreams
and then i can build strategies
when you go on a trip overseas you
always plan it
what are the chances of seeing
everything that you want to see on a
trip if you don't plan
what are your chances of achieving what
you want to achieve in your life without
planning
now you can do this on your own if you
want to do the research
but if you don't have the time and the
resources and the you know the strengths
it's like you can be an accountant on
your own yeah but
you're not going to go and study
accounting i talked to one of the
professor of economics and he said to me
dan i could do this on my own
if i wanted to if i wanted to sit down
and study i'm a professor i can do it
but i don't want to do it because i have
other things to do so i want you to do
it for me
so that's right
what are some of the pain points and the
barriers to the to the average family
that you know would benefit from from
family planning because i think that i
entered this conversation also with with
this almost assumption that you know
it's mainly high net worth families that
are that are even relevant for family
planning but what i'm hearing from you
is that no actually you know it makes
sense that you know when you're talking
about the the empathic need that you
need to have to to to be aligned with
the family values and the goals whether
it's being more risk-averse or whether
it's accomplishing something more
tangible and specific you know what what
are the barriers for the average
families to be able to conduct proper
planning themselves where they would
benefit from having effect from paying a
financial plan or even if it's not a
trivial thing for them to do
um
i think that it's it's more a
psychological barrier
people you know because uh
that's what i think i mean that's what i
feel because anyone who's done it and
will never go back
okay so once you've actually gone into
this process you understand the value
that it brings you
and usually people arrive at the door of
a financial planner not because they
want to plan it's there are those
families
um
but they but because they have an event
that they need to take care of
when you have an event
you start to understand that this event
has a many facets around it so somebody
can come to me and say listen i've got
an inheritance
and you know now it's in you know it's
in real estate and we have to divide it
up between a couple of beneficiaries my
far you know written in the
usually a willer says take it a third
each or a half each or quarter each
whatever the will says and then you have
to start thinking well how do we do this
you know the assets some of them are in
america some of them in europe some of
them are you know and then
and and they're not liquid how do you
divide up these kind of assets what's
the tax you know how does it and then
when you start
going into it you understand that you
can't
divide everything without understanding
you know
what you want to achieve
so each family now we're talking so we
had one family that had large amount of
assets moving it into three families
we have to discuss with the families to
understand what they want to achieve
the family that goes through this
process will start to understand when we
sit down and define what you want to
achieve in your life i think
you start a process where you start to
become the person you want to be
and it's it could be even a very
emotional
uh
event
uh my professor i i taught for graduate
degree in the haifa university
uh for in financial guarantology
and my professor said to me dan
you guys are the social workers of the
financial world
right
that's what it sounds like
yeah so that's i mean we're
professionals we do the math we do the
we understand the implications you know
economics is not a exact science we're
like doctors because we can't promise
the outcome
we know the methodology
and in highest probability you will
achieve what you want to achieve when
you're working with a person like me
but yes you know like a doctor we don't
know what the markets are going to do
no one does if anyone tells you that
they can you know
they can they can they can time markets
and things like that you know no one's
managed to do it up till now
so
basically we're dealing with human
uh emotions
and
and there's no control over that
until now is this idea that you're
helping people
realize where they want to get to and
who they want to be and you know being
the social worker of the financial
industry and simply by even thinking
thinking far down the line i'm imagining
especially for for those families that
don't have the privilege of of being
able to do you know all sorts of
investments and have more limitations
even this this you know simulation and
further planning of what needs to happen
is actually a pretty motivating factor
to help get things in line and and help
them achieve their goals now tell me a
little bit about you know over 42 years
of experience in this field what are
some things that the average family or
individual can do you know either with
financial planner alone to even begin to
think through some of these questions as
exercises to become better you know
financial managers of of their life
well okay uh
we work aligned with the uh
we work online with a academic
methodology
and uh
and uh um basically what we do everyone
can start to think about on their own
so the first thing that we do is to try
and understand the family what kind of
income do they have what kind of
expenses do they have
okay so that's the basics then you want
to understand what assets they have what
liabilities they have
okay then how does their cash flow move
around
you know what kind of things what kind
of things can happen to them
after you do that then you sit down and
define what you want to achieve
and what you need in order to achieve it
so let's say
you know one of your life goals is to
retire comfortably
okay and live the life that you're used
to living so you can continue living
along with your family exactly the life
that you're living in you know give your
grandchildren presents and and help your
children
uh with with homes or without you or
with education whatever you define for
your own then you sit down and say okay
how with this do i do that
yeah and then you are trying that's
where you got into the investment side
so we say okay what kind of investments
i can can i uh can i uh expose myself to
without
taking risking the family's future
so i don't want to bet my my bet all of
the resources of the family on the fact
that the market will go up and say okay
if the market goes up i'll leave a life
that's quite good and if the market goes
down
you know
maybe we'll have to get rid of one or
two kids
or something like that
so you know or they won't have education
or they won't be able to have
so right
basically it's it's
uh and then you want diversification
because you you have to understand that
you know
betting everything on a sector even if
the sector sounds great on a geography
even i would you know
diversification is is sectors
geographies
asset classes different things like real
estate and uh and infrastructure a
little bit of a little bit of everything
because markets
if they go down something always goes up
okay there's never it's not everything
collapses at the same time
so you want to be exposed to a wide
variety of stuff and and usually not
everything goes bad so if something goes
bad other something will do much better
than you expected and that way you'll
achieve approximately what you want to
achieve
then you do the then you want to sit
down and do sensitivity studies you say
okay now i've i know what i've done
i've built some kind of a strategy
around the investments
now what will happen if
what will happen if there's a market
crash what will happen if the dollar
goes up god dollar goes down what will
happen if you know if
if if china disappears or the economy
not the country
okay so what will happen in all these
kinds of things where am i invested what
will be what how it will affect my
future will i be able to continue living
that life and if i could if the answer
is no then you have to start thinking
about alternatives or hedging or all
kinds of strategies in order to build
what we call a risk a risk management
strategy
from there we move to creating passive
income
people aren't aware
passive income
for everyone at every age
should be a major focus
the only thing that will that can really
promise your future is having something
that works while you're not working
so if you're not working and you need
income
if you have
a strategy where you can create income
for the family through dividends through
rental income through
um
through uh gains that you can
that you can take out all kinds
you build a strategy to create passive
income
and it already starts when you're young
and starts to grow as you move forward
okay
then of course tax planning is really
important to get into the taxes
it's you don't plan tax after the event
happens
you plan tax before
so you need to know implications if you
and you have to understand today's world
is a world of a multi-jurisdictional
world we're everywhere here you're in uh
in stanford in in in the united states
i'm in london we're talking about
israelis we're talking about
everyone is moving around today so we're
crossing borders
with our investments with our businesses
with our lives with our families
and this has implications which nobody
deals with
so usually we talk to professionals in
the country that we live in
or we're working in
and they don't look at the implications
a financial planner looks at a family
she has to look at everything so he has
to understand this whole everything
around it and we need to do that when
we're doing the tax planning
and the last thing that we do is looking
at how
what will happen when we need to
transfer this money or assets from
generation to generation
and we need to plan it properly because
if we plan it properly
then the chances of it arriving
okay you work all your life you
accumulate assets who do you want to
give it to the government
to a lawyer or to your family you make
that decision today because if you leave
that open
everybody will be taking the part of
your pie except for the people that you
really want them
to take it
and and you know i'll tell you something
about this intergenerational transfer of
assets
we have children
you think they're living in harmony and
they probably are
but then there's grandchildren when you
pass away
your grandchildren or even your
great-grandchildren may already be
lawyers and accountants
and the worst thing that can happen is a
young lawyer
a young lawyer who thinks he knows
everything and creates unbelievable term
oil in the family
and then you have partners
you don't know who they are even today
your children and your grandchildren are
going to have partners maybe they'll be
nice people then maybe they won't
so do you want to accumulate assets all
your life to give to some stranger who's
treated your family very badly
all these things you know you if you if
you if
you know if you prepare yourself
then
the chances of them happening to your
family will be very small
and or non-existent because you know we
can completely wipe out these kind of
risks when you sit down and you think
about it most people never even think
about these issues
when you sit down and think about it and
you build a strategy
then the chances of
living the life that you want to live
that you dream about
is uh in much higher probability
very very cool and dan i really want to
thank you for coming and sharing with me
your insights in your journey i can
definitely see your fascination and your
inspiration where you drive from and
what i'm really curious about though is
what are some words that you would use
to describe yourself or if i were to ask
any of your clients or your partners how
what what are two or three words they
would describe dan dobry
i think that passion is
really because i'm very passionate about
my profession
i'm passionate about the families that i
it's been a great honor for me to help
people
i've been in this i've done 42 years
i've helped i've talked i've also i'm
also a teacher and i talk like a teacher
unfortunately or fortunately
so uh yeah i love teaching i love
transferring knowledge to others
i also love helping families i'm
passionate i think that um
i ca i think that everybody understands
that i really care
i think definitely he definitely he
definitely resonates through this it
doesn't matter and for me i have to tell
you because michael you asked me about
you know whether we only deal with the
ultra high net worth and all that kind
of stuff here so i deal with them of
course because they're the people that
come to me with the most amount of
problems people
you know who accumulate a lot accumulate
a lot of problems as well
but
uh for me
people are people it doesn't i don't
care who they are if someone comes to me
and asks me a question i'll always
answer the questions
because and that it's not an issue of
money it's an issue of of a calling this
is what i do this is why i was this is
why i exist this is my destiny and you
know and i and and for me it's always
been a great honor to be able to help
anyone
i love it i love it and and what are
some other words that you have
um
well um
this is it's been a great journey for me
uh i i think that uh we all should
understand you know that that i mean i'm
i'm not young anymore i've been 42 years
in the profession but i still wake up
every morning passionate about what i do
excited about the future
and i still believe with with all my
heart that the greatest things that i'm
going to do are before me and not behind
me
so
i believe uh
in i think that that's a lesson
that i hope my children will also
get from me
you know i we don't know how long we're
going to live but as long as we're
living enjoy what you've got
do the best you can
help wherever you can
you know
there's a saying that said you make a
living from what you get but you make a
life from what you give
i love so always and and try and keep
that balance
of getting and giving
and i think that if you if you manage to
find that balance
you'll see that you'll live a life not
of of of
of value
and
of satisfaction
and you know and and that's i don't
think anyone can ask for more in their
lives
dan on this optimistic note i really
want to thank you for the time and the
energy this was fantastic and really
enjoyable and i learned a lot thank you
for the great work that you're doing and
all the families that you've impacted
and continue to impact and stay safe and
stay healthy thank you
[Music]
you